So you just answer the question of what app
do you want to build for your final project? In
this question, you're going to determine in more detail exactly who
you're building this app for. And in the next question,
you'll actually can start the high level flow for
this use, but let's stay focused here. So the flow
for what you'll do in this question itself. Is first,
you'll find a potential user. This could be a friend,
co-worker, family member. Somebody who you think could
ever feasibly want to use the app you described
here. Then you're actually going to do some very
basic user-experience research. This will essentially be an interview
with this person you know. We'll try and
figure out the attributes about them as they pertain
to the app you want to build. Now doing
this is really hard, user research is not easy.
And we've provided a privy template which includes some suggested
questions and categories of questions to think about. Once you've
done your user research, you'll actually create a persona in
this case, for the person you interviewed. Again, the template's
going to be really helpful for this step. Some really key
points when you're thinking about user research. First, be quiet.
And by that, I mean the other person should be
doing most of the talking. Try not to interrupt and
definitely don't ever tell them they're wrong. Second, is to ask open questions.
And by this, I mean, let's say you were to make a music app
for this person. You shouldn't ask a question like: how much do you enjoy
listening to music in the car? Rather, ask when do you listen to music?